Why is the world warming up?
Let's think of Earth for just a moment as a greenhouse.
Every second, a huge amount of energy...
...smashes into our greenhouse.
Our atmosphere, the glass roof and walls, reflect some of that energy,...
...but most of it passes right through and heats everything up.
Much of that heat used to escape back into space,...
...keeping us at a stable, warm temperature.
But then something changed.
Humans began to spew enough carbon dioxide...
...to fill billions of greenhouses each day.
It makes the glass of our greenhouse thicker.
Thicker glass means heat escapes into space much more slowly.
And don't forget, energy from the sun is still streaming in...
...just as quickly as before.
The result is a planet with temperatures too hot for our liking...
...and and eventually living.